what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports you know in csgo
there are a few things sexier than the
one tap just left clicking on a head and
watching it explode so satisfying right
it's their cheese side where they really
struggle now before we get into the list
guys there was a huge debate in the
office about what a one tap actually is
dude Eagle head shots count should they
be on this list should they get their
own separate list at the end of the day
we decide to compromise and give you one
mega list with the best one taps and one
digs but if you think one ding should
get their own top 10 list let us know in
the comments below we can probably make
it happen oh and one more thing guys I'm
gonna need you to go ahead and give that
subscribe button just one tap thank you
very much without further ado here are
the top 10 one taps from csgo kicking
off our list is none other than cold
Zahra once again reminding us just how
good he is playing on nuke against g2
eSports at IEM Oakland 2017 cold kicks
off the play with a dirty D ganar PK
before delivering a crispy one tap two
shocks last time this happened it was
cut way too close
dropping shots without him even touching
the ground that is from one csgo God to
another number nine C's simple giving
Team Liquid a taste of what they've been
missing since he left landing three
consecutive one taps with the USP I'm
sure he would have probably say it that
you know watch out for connector same
pole what's going on
three one passes a USB because why not
you know what I mean look at this I was
the only classic
coming in at number eight is Dennis
melting 3g2 players with a USP so fast
that you'll miss it if you blink good on
these pistols to start that momentum our
fast play on point all three kills again
picking him up is the world's best
pistol not more fitting than he does
that in the second half unbelievable
housing down nine rounds to one in the
quarterfinals of Dreamhack masters Las
Vegas 2017 ninjas in pyjamas needed
something truly magical to get them back
in the game
pipe stepped up conjuring up this grouse
ak-47 double one town don't interrupt
them just yet so at least they'll
succeed but they need to win this oh my
what are you doing taking down clave and
device and making it look easy perfect
work from Pius and then that position is
so incredibly powerful if you don't have
Molotov support from and number six
we've got automatic with the digue
against complexity on train automatic
treats the a site like a firing range
weaving in and out of the train cars
pulling off this sweet 4k with taps
crispier than a bucket of deep-fried
chicken very patient still two players
back by IV one man longest in sight and
there it is
automatic that's incredible for
automatic as he finds a third as well
but how have they let him walk in no one
even looking at a main and they know
they're against crystals he's got I
think one of these rounds missed or was
that for headshots for I think he hits a
body shot he axed a one body shot but
then follows it up either way you look
impressive again how do they leave a man
completely open our next set of worn
taps came up when it mattered the most
in the grand finals of IEM katowice 2017
down a map to faze clan and trailing by
two rounds on overpass Dupree put a
straw 'less on his back with this insane
ace with the deagle including three
consecutive one-two
that selection because here is going to
be pressure but you see know that the
box off people works though vision
[Applause]
okay Dupree that's starting to arrive
now they needed that round desperately
just designee little waggle dance and P
do fifties and they're free with the ace
phenomenal ran from him look how good
that's what that thought that shot my
god
so sick this one's gonna be a little
shorter than our last view but it's just
as nasty scream has one single bullet
left in his a K as he enters the bee
apartments to challenge the likes of fur
and coldzera with the bomb down yeah
he's got one foot in it now the purpose
scream makes me scream oh my god that's
so disgusting and number three we've got
another otherworldly one tap from scream
once again beating up on the Brazilians
landing a split second one tap in
mid-air with his victim jumping over
boxes at CT spawn this brag had to have
FNX rethinking his entire life because
the CT side is their better side it's
their cheese side where they really
struggle at ESL one New York 2017 phase
plan just couldn't be touched with the
European super team failing to drop a
single map during the entire tournament
but even after the mastery they showed
reaching the finals Niko still managed
to shock us all fenced in by three
players on infernos B bomb site Niko
tells Guardian to hold his beer and goes
to work on the hapless victims of Team
Liquid in the last row so to see in this
the auto sniper that Gibson
in the back of the site and he's got
accuracy oh that's so so good there's
nothing you can do against this this is
why it's considered the world's best
plan this third killer's wow what a
monster I'll say one of I think cool
five shots five kills coming in at
number one we have a series of surgical
one taps from XMS that will have you
questioning reality itself XMS plays a
one-man game of counter-strike here
surgically picking off penguins entire
roster with just five gonna let it go
and take all three X so that's what the
deve suddenly turns this around though
goes head it takes two lives as he shuts
this down does pick up the bomb gonna be
trying to finish up half PETA
so does horribly miss it smart face the
nice fire show within this guy hyper
could be watching with his boots to come
on through and she gets the angle happy
gonna go down oh this man is a master of
the taps right now goto gets himself a
third and to watch out he knew there was
a playoff here to what saying oh my god
so that's what is wrong with you he's
gonna go ahead and get for this my
thirty five four bullets the whole round
that is so ridiculous no kit for Spiro
so it's positioning being this distant
it's actually quite reasonable in Spiro
tries to pay them in one five shots five
shot five kills
accidents it isn't human but I didn't
want to changed it in this last round
that's that's about one of the best aces
I've ever seen yeah hands down that way
that always split no matter look at this
well guys that's our list like I said at
the start if you think one deep should
get their very own top ten list let us
know in the comments we can probably
make it happen thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button